we're very fortunate to have have these
these people here to weigh in and I hope
you think carefully about the questions
that you that you ask them just to ask
the best questions that you can I'm
gonna ask them each to please introduce
themselves a little bit just make some
brief comments about their their their
situation and then we've got some
questions prepared and we will go
through and and give each one a chance
to lead the answer to the question but
then also give everyone a chance to
answer it and then we'll leave 25
minutes or so for questions from you all
here in the class and then and then the
last 10 or 15 minutes for closing
statements from each of the panelists so
without further ado please introduce
yourselves I'm David Kennedy at class
and id8 here at the GSB when I left here
and I went to management consulting
which I've done a little bit of prior to
business school as well it also had some
operating experience albeit quite light
before business school after three years
I did a search fund with a partner of
mine a gentleman called Mike's Merck
Loeb who's not here we bought a company
called service source it went pretty
well we ran it together and Mike is
still the CEO and chairman there now we
run it jointly for about four years and
about three years ago give or take I
step back from that in a kind of
minority recap deal took a bunch of my
chips off the table took some time off
and then founded a private equity firm
so I've kind of been on both sides of
the equation here being the search
funder and I've also you know sort of
sat on the side of the private equity
guys who have dabbled a little bit with
the sponsored search idea without
prosecuting with great vigor and that's
where I'm now a firm called sarin
capital which I found another just be
grad of 98 Sean Callahan I also was 98
out of Kellogg I was an operating
consultant for about three or three
years before Kellogg then went back did
a dual degree program and engineering
management and business similar I think
Stanford has one as well came out did
management consulting for
a year but quickly sort of decided it
was time to go into the operating
company went into a venture back startup
as a kleiner back sorry back she was
with how Lia who is a professor at
Stanford that was probably Series B at
the time so it wasn't true
no Series A but got a good experience
there in a growing company then stepped
out went to to Oracle and spent about
four years there I guess about actually
about three years it just seemed like
four and then I left and went to
business engine which was another
venture back company but there's
probably Series C at least by the time I
joined this is more of a midsize company
and growing I had a role of I was
running our sort of sales and business
development and then became the GM of
international operations when the then
CEO was a very very persuasive gentleman
convinced me that it wasn't in that bad
of shape and so he was definitely
persuading me cuz when I got there it
was but it's a great experience lived in
London for a couple years
got the international operations in
better order the company overall we had
a good turnaround made us appealing sold
the business in February 2007 I had an
employment agreement there until about
August of 2007 so it gave me some time
to think about what was next and that's
where I sort of started thinking about
what we're talking about today and so
when I got back to the States sort of
had teed up you know the normal rounds
of discussions and sort of looked at
taking another general ultimately ended
up going with our plane investors as a
you know executive in residence or you
guys called sponsored search so we
acquired why lighting I was there for
about eleven months before it was
acquired we acquired it on September 5th
2008 sir high-end modern retailing if
you guys are in the mood for lights or
furnishings about a week before Lehman
imploded so I think some of the things
we should talk about is when that
investment thesis doesn't turn out to
reality what do you know the type of
experience you want to have in hand to
sort of help you guide through that I've
been there for about a year love it and
happy to be here my name senior resume
so if they've read that they prepared
for class today which I'm confident 100%
of the people have well
I'm serious about that then but so you
can be confident that I'm very trusting
so I'll be pithy I like David from
Dublin Ireland originally like David
followed him to Russia at some point in
time and then of course follow them over
here and then I met him and of course
Alan being a small country you know we
know some similar people I did a search
fund coming straight out of school
looked at doing some other
entrepreneurial stuff did talk to some
folks about the sponsored search and
ultimately decided to go the search fund
route with a partner and we've been
operating the business for close on five
years and one of the interesting things
like many search funds are buyout has
somewhat morphed into a startup so here
we are eight years out of business
school and we're running a startup and
running very hard and fast and we could
an exciting growing company hey I'm
Michael sanabria and I plus 93
so I started about ten years after I
graduated doing a search fund so for me
I always knew I wanted to do something
entrepreneurial and so the choices I
made both in terms of choosing Stanford
and then after Stanford the kind of
operational decisions I made going to
Apple as a product manager and so on and
so forth going to increasingly smaller
companies we're all targeted to address
some of the things that you guys brought
up which is get that operational
experience I thought would help me
successful so I waited about 10 years
until I joined the company in Novato and
then decided that it was time to go out
and do a search and at that time I chose
the self-funded search model and then
with the company now about seven seven
years will be this year so I'm going to
start off with some questions
you know just in following the
discussion today in class all the first
question I'll ask is is you know Michael
asked you to answer it first if I could
but then if each of you would please
that'd be very helpful what do you see
is the biggest benefits to the
acquisition path to entrepreneurship
and and what do you see is the biggest
risks so for me the the question is its
it depends for me personally when I
started this search I had a pretty good
idea when I pretty good idea I knew the
industry I wanted to go into
I knew basically the idea that I wanted
to pursue and so for me the benefit of
going to an acquisition was I wasn't
trying to create some new way of
creating Ram it wasn't a high technology
solution it's very blocking and tackling
I was going into a very mature industry
where I felt I could bring some
strategic channel partnerships and a
customer centric focus to sales
marketing and I didn't need to I felt
like by acquiring a going concern that
had folks with industry experience
ongoing operations I could bring my
ideas and get that more quickly than
going out and starting from from from
scratch so for me the benefit was being
able to look for the type of company
that had what I needed but was missing
what it what I felt I could bring and
then add value through that the the
downside in my particular model going
self-funded was I you find yourself a
little lacking perspective and expertise
in terms of not sourced the operational
side but probably the the deal side and
when you're going self-funded there are
a lot of resources I called upon a lot
of classmates have done similar things
so that was a good thing for me but
there's a limited amount of time that
they're willing or able to spend and so
that was probably something that hurt me
and then the two big things the downside
were in terms of acquisition was the the
baggage that can become pretty
overwhelming because some of you
mentioned that when you get inside spend
a lot of time early on overcoming some
cultural issues that were pretty tough
to identify in the search and
acquisition phase but I spent a lot of
time with those once I actually bought
the company and then the the last thing
we're in this or the acquisition is
discovering those rotten Easter eggs
things that just were hidden below the
surface that hits you
you know so you have all these great
plans what you're going to do in the
first hundred days and then you come in
and you find things that were completely
unexpected that all sudden divert your
energy and attention risks of the
acquisition path I don't know if they're
the biggest ones but some that you know
come to mind here as we're sitting it's
it's a it's definitely an entree into
entrepreneurship you know I didn't I'd
had ideas before I'm just the timing
didn't work out I was in the UK in 93
having come back from the States for the
first time and was trying to sell
everyone on coffee and a paper cup
telling them who was going to be huge
and I couldn't convince the soul and I
knew nobody in business and I knew
nothing about business and I had long
hair in a guitar and it just wasn't
going my way and I figured I got to
learn something about business well you
know several years later the coffee
things sort of panned out a little bit
and I didn't have that next idea and had
some that I thought were okay and I
wanted to build a great business and
this was how I was going to do it
it was and so it's an act it's a route
one thing won't benefit up the
acquisition path that's not being
mentioned here today I think is if you
get into a company of the right scale
and the right size and that is decent
frequently actually bizarrely a lot of
the skills that you gain in this room
can be of more benefit than in a smaller
company I think it was Jason you were
commenting on smaller you might you
might feel more control over the thing
but if you get into a larger company I
frequently think you might have some
decent management under you who can look
after the day-to-day tactical and you
may be of some benefit in thinking
through strategic issues which people in
this room are more teed up for I saw in
Michaels write-up that he suffered like
I did from not having decent management
under so you're dragged into the
tactical so I think actually acquisition
path if you get into the right sort of
vehicle it can really tee you up it's a
great model if you get a good come
but if that's a big if
biggest risks been mentioned several
times you're inheriting someone else's
problems and someone else's team and
coach which aren't necessarily positive
things if Dave Duds and I remember
impressing this upon upon us if you get
into a bad industry or an industry where
the tide just isn't going the right way
that's that's just not fun you can push
against the tide for a while but if the
industry is not going the right
direction
it's tough and then finally the biggest
risk I think ultimately is time you can
spend a lot of time just not moving
quickly enough so I think it was Jessica
talked about figure out if you're gonna
fail or not you know if you're in a bad
industry or you're in a bad company or
if you're gonna fail I'd like to do it a
lot faster you know one of my mantras in
the company now is let's move faster
let's fail faster you know talking to
the salespeople get knows faster and
speed up that sort of what's going to
take place so a little bit again I'm
going to start with Michaels it depends
you know I think that's the great thing
about this class is it's not right or
wrong but we're going to tee it up for
it the why I acquired personally versus
found it is you know I took a lot of the
entrepreneur class without in school did
new product competitions really love the
idea of starting my own company but I
never had a killer idea I think if I had
a killer idea that I really had passion
about maybe I would have taken that
route but I didn't but what I did have
passion about was creating an
organization that could be lasting that
can really really grow and so I loved
the idea of setting a vision getting a
team aligned against that vision and
really growing that business which is
going to make you you know successful I
think in business but it also just I
have passion about doing that which you
brought up about so very much so that
can happen in any of these three models
for me that was one of the criteria
because I don't want to spend seven
years of my life on something I don't
have passion about I think life's
definitely too short for that but you
know again why do the the through
acquisition versus tarp I do enjoy
because of that I enjoy building off the
base and having
as it turns out there wasn't a whole lot
of vision when I you know got into the
company even though it was 3 million
EBIT dia business good-sized business
didn't mean it had a good vision meant
they did some things right it didn't
mean they had a management team as it
turns out they didn't but there's a lot
of things you can work with and so you
get to work there's tools if you're you
know if you feel good about the
management skills so that that's been
great I mean and just the idea of you
get to to go through the process of
trying to find a company by learned a
lot there even though I had done that a
few times but for a company not really
you know which I was going to end up
running learned a lot of things through
that process which I'll take with me
through the rest of my career
then you know obviously you get a chance
to run a company which which you know at
Jeff's he said this at this point in
your career that's an interesting
opportunity and you have to decide to
when you're ready I know the CEO of
business engine which was the cool you
know the job I took before this he was
my age we actually graduated from
Kellogg together he was ready to be a
CEO after four years out of business
school I wasn't at the time I but I'd
say when I walked out of being the GM I
felt ready like I felt like Victor you
mentioned it's like you've got a team of
people who whose lives you you know you
you play a big role in I mean you gotta
do the right things for the company
which sometimes they're hard decisions
then the day that I wanted to feel like
I was ready to lead that before I was
going to take that take that on so I
think that it's a wonderful opportunity
and it just felt as a natural next
career step for me given I didn't have a
killer product idea the risks you know
we've talked about this before but I
think you could spend two years looking
let's say towards the tail under that
you close the deal four or five years
running it and it let's say it's a zero
it's a donut I mean great personal life
experiences but you know if if you're
seven years out of Business School and
that's that's your post post you know
graduation track there's some concerns I
think are valid ones to really think
about I think for me at least I felt
like it's going to be it's going to be a
natural career path for me so I'm kind
of mitigating that risk so not just
financially but career-wise
great thank you David the biggest
benefits and of the acquisition path
entrepreneurship and the biggest risk so
I think the reason that I did it and
which for me was the biggest benefit of
the lot was just the ability to control
my own destiny and I felt that you know
I've worked for big companies I'd worked
for consulting firms and through them
four other big companies and I felt like
you know I kind of wanted to instead of
be the person on the sidelines who's
coaching people taking the shots I want
to be a guy with the ball in my hands in
the last of 60 seconds of the game and
be able to make things happen and I felt
confident in my ability to really drive
performance and and I thought that I
should gain the benefits of that both
the psychic and the financial and you
know I wanted to earn the marginal
product of my labor if you want to put
it in economic terms but the reality is
I felt like I could control things and
that I had learnt enough and I was ready
and I really wanted that control in that
economy and so that was the reason that
I did it and for me this was a you know
I think the benefits that's benefits
versus wash and for me I didn't have a
great startup idea maybe I might have
done a start-up at the time and I had a
great idea but for me it was versus
being a GM of a division for a large
company and maybe working with a private
equity firm with their portfolio
companies those were things that were
possible for me that I explored as I you
know kind of decided to take the leap to
do a search I think in retrospect the
risk that because I'm always I'm often
in an unusual situation when I sit in
these panels because I did the search
fund it went very well and I think it
was a dumb idea and I wouldn't do it
again
so let's get that out of the table
straight away the reason and I the
reason that I feel that way is because I
think the risks to your point Peter are
are large and I think particularly their
non diversifiable risks you know the
fact that the bulk of search phones
don't work
you know they either don't buy a company
or if they do they lose money for their
investors or you know even in fact I
think the worst of all scenarios is you
buy something and you chug along four
five six seven eight years and you make
no money for anybody and your careers in
tatters and you haven't made any cash at
all you haven't been paid terribly well
and you look at your peer group that's
out there from the search
side of things and they're flying you
know there are CEOs of things now or
GM's of things now or what have you and
it's got at least as I can tell having
been fortunate enough to be in the top
kind of desolate port Isle of search
fund returns got nothing to do with us
and I mean I don't think we're
particularly stupid but I don't think
we're particularly smart either when I
look at my peers who did search funds
and I think most folks who come to
Stanford evolves be in the top decile of
anything they've ever done or top
percentile and they hear that you know
top decile does great and search funds
and the like sign me up I'm gonna be top
decile and the reality is these small
businesses have massive risk that's
really hard to tell before you buy they
have usually significant customer
concentration particularly because you
typically buying small fast growth
businesses what we tend to do is
somebody's got proof of concept they got
a couple big customers you hope you're
going to take it from a couple to 20 or
from 10 to 100 or whatever it ends up
being and hey the customers change their
mind your customer merges it gets bought
it goes bankrupt there's a set of things
that are just endemic to small business
that are highly risky and to me in
retrospect that risk is kind of twofold
I mean the first one is you know there's
just so there's just a financial
economic set of risks that go along you
know kind of with this process and the
second one though which is kind of sort
of a harder one to articulate is what's
the risk that you're not actually ready
to be a CEO and what's the risk to your
career of the fact you've now jumped
into that position which as people sort
of jokingly refer to makes you
constitutionally unemployable to do
anything other than be a CEO and you
never learned how to be a CEO properly
you never learned how to bring in
revenue you never learned what it's like
to make a quarter and to lose a quarter
you never learned what it's like to
build a team well or to build a team
badly to fire people you never learned
those things properly because you never
had a mentor you never went to a
well-run company you popped into a two
million dollar EBIT a business and you
struggled there for a while and it's
still at two three million dollar EBIT a
business and you never learnt the you
know you never apprenticed to the to the
skillset of being a great manager and so
to me those are those are kind of you
know those are the core risks that that
are associated to the search thank you
the class is not over yet
but I think this the experience of this
panel highlights really a lot of the
things that we talked about today and
the things that we're gonna explore in
the next two weeks so to keep going why
let's see why did you why did it make
sense for you to try this approach at
the point in career point in your career
where it you've kind of answered that
already each of you but I'll go and
actually shift and Karen if you'll love
if you'll go next and I'll try and keep
in this order of shifting the first
question for the next so why did it make
sense at that point in your career so
probably coming off of that Starbucks
experience I went out trying to get some
business skills and I specifically went
long story but I ended up in Russia
knocking on doors of Western
institutions looking for business
experience and didn't care how I got it
ultimately there came a point when I'm
in New York I'm in consulting it's in
the.com times when everyone's knocking
your door saying hey come work for us
and there's lots of money to be made and
I got the promotion past the NBA hurdle
and it turns out I was really good at
this consulting gig and life could be
easy doing this and it wasn't what I
wanted to do I wanted to go build
companies and I think Shawn sort of
described it pretty well it's this
personal fulfillment and that's what I
wanted and you know part of it would
come through that Starbucks think party
to come up I grew up in Dublin when it
was huge unemployment today I think 18
percent was the typical where I grew up
lots of unemployed fall there's a nice a
father's because typically the mothers
weren't working until the father got
unemployed and they go looking for a
cleaning job or something and I knew
from the factories where my parents work
that good managers could make a huge
difference and I saw the standard of
management that was out there in the
average company I was like I can make a
difference so there's this twofold
motivation and but so I'm 27 and I'm in
New York and I'm thinking I don't need
this huge money I want to build
thing I'll either start something now or
this place Stanford will have me they
seem to spit out entrepreneurs I'll go
out there and see what that can talk me
off with well this place had means that
that was nice I came out here and I've
got two years of discussing pros and
cons and hearing - a lot of bright
people and that was wonderful
build a great Network but ultimately I
was ready and I was chomping at the bit
and I did believe there's a lot that I
just didn't know I sort of knew I didn't
know I wish I could surround myself with
more smarter folks but it's in the case
tree I mean the first three things
Christian and I had to learn were
selling leading and managing and we're
not done with that I mean the the speed
of I met Joel Peterson out in the
parking lot the speed of learning has
only accelerated since leaving school
and continues to do so and in terms of
there's there's we've had some look I
mean we've had some bad luck perhaps
that maybe we weren't kicked out of the
game early on and gone and done
something else we persisted onwards
we've had the good luck that we found
something else and and we're running on
that hard but it was just I was I felt
that readiness that's it
I just felt it and I wanted it and there
are risks there and and those risks are
pretty subjective because I think
David's right that looking at your peer
set the green-eyed monster can really
chew you up when I compare myself with a
you know the couple of classmates are
driving the Lamborghinis from the choice
of cars in the big parking lot there has
and there are some of those guys but it
that's not what I want to do I want to
build something so that's why how you
got in your career to that point is
there is there anything else is why you
picked that point versus another point
in your career to do it so I really just
I felt ready in my gut that it was time
that that I could lead a company
successfully versus being a GM which was
a great training but it is different
when you don't have that see
to sort of go to and sometimes to tell
you you can't do things when you were
like because now you know you still have
the board by the way the board can be
positive even in a sponsored search
hopefully we'll have time to talk about
but I just I was ready and so I didn't
feel like frankly it was a big of a risk
as it it would have felt to me before
and we can talk about why we'll talk a
little bit about that later but David
hit on a lot of points it wasn't the
strategy experience there's a lot I'm
sure everybody in this room is very very
smart and probably pretty strategic
thinkers it was having a number having
to hit that thing every quarter or not
hit it figure out how to conjure up the
revenues to hit that right build a team
it was that kind of stuff that really I
felt comfortable in my own skin at this
point managing people and that's what
gave me the confidence it wasn't that I
could out think the next person felt
ready - you were just prepared - would
you have anything better yeah well I
think in retrospect I wasn't and I
thought I was you know and and so the
way that I think about timing is I think
that this is an inherently kind of risky
thing and so if you're gonna do it
that's fine you're gonna take on risk
it's like everything else you do when
you take on risk you then work out how
do you minimize the chances of things
will go badly and also if things do go
badly you you know kind of hope for the
best and plan for the worst
that's what CEOs do all the time and
sort of given that I would do it if I
were doing it all again and wouldn't
want to do it I do one show on them did
it I do it haven't been a GM somewhere I
do it having had all of that experience
because I think you're far better off we
screwed up a bunch in the first couple
years because we were learning how to do
the job and in retrospect that didn't
kill us and it certainly probably left
some money on the table but it didn't
kill us and but I'd be far better off
haven't done it having had the you know
having had some sort of general
management experience and then secondly
as I said I think if it all goes
pear-shaped which can happen you need an
exit strategy
and I think to the extent that you have
built a brand and you've built a set of
skills and a network through having a
strong operating career prior to doing
it you're in far better shape than you
are when you know you do it sort of
straight out of business school or I did
it you know business school plus
McKinsey which is you know it's a little
bit better than straight out of business
school that I think not a lot and so
you know at some point when that fails
if you've you know tried to buy
something you finally buy it into
Shawn's point you're like 7 years in at
some points you're no longer kind of
somebody who worked at Goldman Sachs and
ta associates and has a you know
Stanford MBA you're now just some guy
who you know kind of round a company
kind of badly for half a decade and you
know spent seven years of their career
making no money for anybody and I think
you want someone to fall back on and
preferably that's a really successful GM
experience prior to doing it is your
comment about three years of McKinsey
not being much different a comment on on
the nature of the work it is I look at a
great time McKenzie I think it's a
fantastic firm it's a wonderful
consulting experience I'm totally with
Shawn what makes a difference in being
ready to do this stuff it's having to
bring in a number and it's having a
managing team of folks and it's happened
to hire in a sudden to fire and it's
it's the things that general managers do
all the time and you don't learn a
Bissell school and you don't learn in
consulting
and I think that set of skills is just
it's invaluable it's just hard to do
anyway other than through apprenticeship
I think Michael so since clear role and
file an agreement about the operational
experience and managing people all that
stuff so so I'll focus on instead is
what what was key for me after ten years
is I had a much better perspective an
idea of what I wanted and so part why
chose self-funded versus the traditional
responsive sponsored model I had a
pretty clear idea of the endgame and for
me the end game wasn't to buy a company
flip it and retire in five years I gone
through I graduated 93 a little
something called the Netscape Browser
it was launched around that time and I
lived through that entire boom and bust
and and to echo what David said I saw a
lot of really smart people make nothing
out of it and I saw a lot of really not
so smart people pick the right company
at the right time and make a lot of
money and and it kind of wasn't there
wasn't any rhyme and reason around how
hard you worked there was a lot of
timing there was a lot of luck and so so
I had a pretty clear idea that that now
my in-game might time I knew what I
wanted and it was I wanted to go out buy
a company
build a company and I expected and fully
expected that was something I was going
to be with for 15 20 years my goal was
to Jenna
right income my goal was to get it big
enough to kind of step back and just
play a strategic role day-to-day but
still stay engaged because after ten
years I realized that was still
important to me I can't conceive of a
world where I just retire and do nothing
I want to stay engaged and want to be
you know still stimulated by something
important and meaningful that I've built
so so for me what was key is I had a
very clear idea of what I wanted and
what I expected to get out of it and so
that's what we made it the right time
for me thank you
the next question I'd like to put to you
for is and Shawn I'll start with you is
is how did you in track attract your
investors to your to your search fund
and your case agus was alpine so it was
a it was different but it's they didn't
just magically appear how did you
attract him and then all that's the
others so coming out of Northwestern and
even after that I wasn't I guess aware
of the Entrepreneurship through
acquisition the search fund so I just
knew what I was trying to do and so when
I knew I had that six months after we
sold the company I started reaching out
to people I knew back in the States and
you know I was Terry I knew I wanted to
be at a growing company like midsize not
venture capital I worked for two venture
backed companies and that wasn't for me
so I it was I just started whittling
down the the private equity firms that I
thought sir we're investing in middle
market companies that were and sort of
the criteria the type of company I'd
like to work with that's how I went
about it
I also worked for GM rules I've got a
hedge of my bets cuz I was bringing home
a wife a kid and a dog so you know had
to start looking so I really the that
was what I didn't tried to be thorough
about it and talk to people you know you
guys call it informational interviews I
learned a lot along the way and just
kind of naturally came to a point where
the Alpine folks were investing in the
types of businesses I was looking for
thought I was looking for because I
wasn't picking an Internet Retailer
going in and I trusted him and you know
we talked a lot about the the board
control issues now those are very rail
and I think those are very real in any
at least you know scenario so anyways I
just felt a good trust for them which
really
made it that pretty easy decision for me
and they were crazy enough to bring me
on board attract investors in three
weeks yeah I mean you know it was three
weeks because we spent a bunch of time
kind of pre marketing before we went out
to sell so that number was kind of
uncomfortable with it kind of going out
there reality has I'd been thinking
about and talking about doing a search
for two years three years and so you
know I already knew a whole bunch of
folks including couple folks you're
gonna have in the class here on Thursday
were just super people who helped me out
through that process with will and with
will and Bill
I think it's that's a little bit tied to
me with the question of what are you
looking for with your investors if
you'll so I'm gonna kind of answer both
if that's okay
I like this sort of set of things we had
up there but particularly the fact that
dollars is first is is pretty important
and it should be first second third
fourth fifth and then you know somewhere
around sixty can start talking about
other things the what we ended up doing
was we sort of decided first of all we
built a list of I think literally 200
people that we thought might plausibly
research fund investors for us then we
worked through who had real deep pockets
and for us that meant that they would be
prepared to put of the order of a
million bucks in cash into one single
deal because we wanted to have the
ability to put fifteen million dollars
in equity and we only wanted to have 15
investors and then we kind of rank
ordered them based on kind of two
criteria one of which was I well didn't
know the search fund and comfortable
will they be in investing in this model
and the other one was how well do they
know us and folks that were both so who
knew us well and who understood this
model we prioritized first and we
quickly got five of those folks who all
had deep pockets and again some of this
was I'd been talking to some of these
folks forever I'd been you know I've
worked at a company which was a search
front company very successful one and
the two founders were both sort of
prepared to sponsor me through my search
effectively make introductions for me
Mike similarly through his career had
had you know had done some fantastic
things for a couple of very wealthy
highly respected deal people they wanted
to back him and so suddenly within about
you know in a couple days or
pre-launched if you will we had five to
15 taken with folks who are real name
investors who had real money knew us
really well and so it meant a lot when
we go to other people who say it's at
and he know who X is and they know that
X knows us really well and that just
made it so that much easier when you get
both of those cross sections of know you
and know the search and they're
well-respected people as well with with
sort of deep pockets and from then on
it's just that it quickly ran through
from each of those folks that said yes
we sort of said hey can you suggest
another set of folks that you think
would be truly great investors and so we
went down it like that the other thing
that we did was we were very careful
about trying to make sure that with no
concentration of power in our search
fund and there's a there's a theme that
came through the class that I'm sure
we'll talk about in a second which is
control and autonomy on the one hand and
then the flip side of which which is
support and involvement from an investor
on the other Mike and I were decidedly
on one end of the extreme that said we
want to be able to control our destiny
entirely and that means we want a
completely fragmented set of people
investing in us we don't want anybody
who's going to actually own more than
one unit and we don't want anybody who's
going to be able to drive the decision
for the night we buy the company if we
like the company we want to be able to
force it through and so the private
equity funds for example that might
plausibly have invested in us and there
were a few we talked to when we were
basically already sold that way we had
relationships such that when we found
the company if we had a gap we could go
back to those private equity funds and
raise the slot with four million or five
or six or seven or whatever was required
to finish off the acquisition and we've
formed relationships with them that were
solid from that perspective we didn't
have to you know totally we'd only three
units sold and then subsequent to get
lost
we told me hey we've only got one unit
left might you interested I'll terribly
sorry somebody else just took it and
that was kind of the order in which we
said have thought about it so we were
very thought around the order in which
we hit up those those those sets of
folks so for me I was looking for
investors who brought one I'm a
manufacturer so I was looking for
distributors who could bring these sales
and so I went out talking to people that
could actually invest in me and then
turn around have their companies funnel
sales to my company second thing I was
looking for was prior relationships I
had spent a lot of time dealing with
venture-backed company boards and and
saw that what they what they don't
provide I have to smile when I hear some
of the things you guys are looking for
for investors because the
the reality is is they don't have a lot
of time for you they they want the
numbers that's what they care about they
really can't spend or it's gonna choose
to spend that much time gonna shine into
your business so you're not gonna get a
lot a little insight out of them so I
wasn't looking for people necessarily
who were going to provide operational
experience for things of that nature but
I wanted people that I had a
relationship with me so it was that they
went into the deal with a with a basis
and foundation of trust and then I could
goo felt I could grow from there so the
one thing you mentioned that I was done
differently is probably a third really
important thing would have been people
had deeper pockets because I chose
people who you know kind of put the
limit of what they would invest in any
one opportunity and then when I came
back to them later with acquisition
opportunities and I needed more powder
they really weren't there for me they it
was kind of like let's see what we can
do is just go to a bank let's try other
avenues and that and that hurt because
they were in the best position they
weren't unhappy with my performance they
weren't unhappy or they didn't it wasn't
enough sure believing the ideas is sort
of they had already given as much as
they were willing to give and I probably
should have looked at that follow-on
investment isn't a more important
component of who I chose so on the
question of how we attracted our
investors when we went out looking for
money it was a better year after David
went that and we went out in June 2002
and since I knew of three search funds
who went at summer of o1 we met at
summer of o2 well clearly 9/11 had
happened and the dowsed went into a
freefall so when we started raising
money in the middle of June o2
the Dow was at nine seven and by the
time we closed our fund it was at seven
six so it meant that everyone who oughta
have liquid assets to invest in us we
really had to sort of twist their arms
and twist a lot of other stuff with some
pretty brutal implements but it was it
was a classic sales process and someone
said here you know what do you take away
from the the two-year process or that
whole process of looking for money I
think was Victor no okay what do you
take away from the process is looking
for money and then go and looking for
there's lots of skills I mean it's not
the ones I wanted yeah I wanted to get
in and run a business but we got really
good at running a sales process you
first of all you know you've got to come
with the value proposition there's lots
of people out there looking for money in
this brutal time so you've got to come
up with how you're different and when
you're gone in front of a lot of people
your pitch really starts to hum in terms
of the process I think that's what we
were really good at we didn't know
people we just didn't we got a
spreadsheet and we wrote down 70 names
when we started and we actually wrote a
white paper I think the CES has this a
lot of search funders who are looking
for money today are passing this around
but we wrote down 70 names and nine
months later we had a thousand and
seventy names on it and we sat down ups
face to face with over 200 people and
from that 200 people we ended up getting
I think in the search fund something
like 25 people which isn't an ideal
number at all it's way too high but you
know back to David's point it's the
dollars and we were actually looking for
experienced dollars we were looking for
folks who'd run businesses and who could
be value add and by the time we did our
deal because it was such a bad time for
raising money we had 44 people in the
deal and all of those additional people
had come from people we'd hit up along
the way but in terms of the sales
process it was that calling people
saying hey tell them what we're doing
and tell them what we're trying to
achieve and when they try to shut you
off the phone you give them a reason why
they ought to be talking with you on the
phone and ultimately what you're looking
for is two names because if you can get
two names from everybody you're still
alive so I certainly know that I didn't
know Shawn at the time and I didn't know
Lisa at the time but Jim we handed per
Jim we had it for Peter we definitely
had a David we handed everybody four
names and that's how we did it was
classic just pure grind at sales process
so you were all successful in buying a
company and David I think this is yours
Dewar's to start with how is the
experience of actually operating it
different than what you expected
well I think you know you know in in a
few different ways as I said I think one
of the things I you know one of the
things I discovered quickly was that I
wasn't as good as I thought I was and
that there were a set of skills that I
was learning for the first time and as a
result we messed up we messed up with
some of our hiring with some of our
critical hires we messed up in managing
I think our sales process some we messed
up with some of our key key accounts in
terms of account management and so I
think you know one of the first things I
learned was the fact that there were a
set of skills that we were missing and
so that was kind of different I think
secondly we had and this is sort of
similar to the last conversation but we
had pulled together what I still think
of as being a phenomenal board of
directors for a typical search fund
business we had four smart experienced
committed folks sitting on the board who
had great alignment with us and were
relationship type of people and yes the
board experience was a curiously
unsatisfying one for us because kind of
to you know to what sort of you mention
actually by I think almost everybody on
the panel a set of folks who otherwise
have careers and jobs and they were
doing you know important things and who
were managing partners that firms or who
are professors at the GSB or whoever it
is just had very limited time and so
you'd come into board meetings we found
and very quickly it turned into how did
you do over the last 90 days and we said
we did great and they'd say
congratulations do it again and that was
basically you know that was kind of what
our board meetings started to turn into
relatively quickly and again that's not
to knock our board because was a
fantastic set of folks but you're only
going to do they're busy working the
other ninety days you know in the
quarter and one of the things that we
did do was we took on a venture firm
after about 18 months who didn't
actually invest in the company they just
bought shares from these some of the
existing folks and we did it
deliberately to kind of raise the game
not the quality of the board members
because I don't think the quality moved
I think it just stayed extremely high
but we now had somebody whose actual job
it was that we do well and who as a
result came on sales calls and got to
know members of
our executive team a lot better and
became somebody that you could talk to
on a daily basis of that feeling like
you were being a pain in the backside by
calling them and so I you know I think
those are kind of the two pieces one
that we weren't as good as we thought we
were and we were kind of you know ready
to screw up and then secondly well
therefore you need assistance we didn't
really 100% get it from our board and
that's not to knock them it's just you
know the difference between having a
professional set of investors who have
real skin in the game on what you're
doing as opposed to folks who are doing
it as a hobby was was pretty marks they
were it was one war story from really on
something that didn't set hiring sales
key accounts so yeah so the I mean I
think the best one of the lot was we we
invested just a huge amount of time in
getting a VP of Sales and for us this
was a company making hire as far as we
were concerned and we hired an
individual who just had a glowing resume
and who had ended up being president of
a multi-billion dollar public company
and it driven sales at a couple of
technology companies extraordinarily
successfully well multiples larger than
our company was at that point and we
have to fire them within two weeks of
hiring them for a variety of reasons I
won't go into and having agreed with our
board that this was a key hire and
having negotiated an unbelievable
compensation and option package for this
person to have to go back in 14 days
later and say I'm terribly sorry we
screwed up and gotta fire this guy that
was pretty big one thank you
so for me it was a the biggest deviation
was I came from high tech I came from an
industry where my peers the people that
I worked for the people that worked for
me you know had a minimum of an
undergraduate degree many of them had
advanced degrees and so all that
operational experience and supervisor
experience all those things that that
was great
but then when for me I bought a
manufacturing organization where people
were hourly blue-collar it became a very
different management experience and so
fortunately I had the experience to kind
of deal with it but but you just dealing
with a whole different set of issues a
different way to motivate people it's
very different to motivate people in in
my industry and and then it was in in
high tech where everyone had you know
equity and shares and options and and it
did all the right things for the right
reasons so those were the things that
for me deviated a lot was was going from
one environment to the other thinking I
had transferable skills which I think
for the most part worked out but just a
different set of issues operational
issues when I chose to to move so far
from between industries deviated from
what you expected from what I expected
and someone mentioned here they really
wanted to manage people kind of remember
who that was
the bizarre thing is I meet so many
business owners who are like crap I hate
managing people this is hell get rid of
these people it's bizarre I never
understood why search funders like the
guys who worked in private equity firms
would write down in their books one of
their key ratios and sort of
ascertaining the quality of the
businesses the revenues per employee
it's like I'm like who cares about
seventy thousand over seven hundred
thousand the reality is it's a lot
easier to run a business when it's seven
hundred thousand per employee than
70-thousand managing people is really
hard and just that's probably the
biggest thing by far i justwe
underestimated
and what else lack of I've written down
here we're just underleveraged and I
think this goes to David's experience
thing of you know today I've know going
into a business crap I don't care what
this is doing to the cash flow we got to
get in a more leveraged management team
here today we need to make differences
immediately I know going into a deal
that I need to raise an extra half a
million from the investors so that in
order to do these things rather than try
and keep the investment to the minimum
possible in terms the under leverage
there's you know the lack of tactical
management or other executives the
difference in work force you know you
start to employ you know college grads
from nice colleges and it starts to
really make a difference in the sort of
your daily experience
my daddy experienced another thing on
the lack of experienced you know David
mentioned getting rid of a VP of Sales
after two weeks it took us nine months
that's our lack of experience you know
we just should have taken the guy back
shot him very quickly it doesn't matter
by the way one sort of business group
I'm in the chair was asked recently do
you think Kieran really does have a
stick that he takes to people and the
answer is no the torture implements the
stick the shooting it's all a figure of
speech and the final thing on different
from the expectations it's the lack of
board oomph
it's just I think David had a far
superior board to us I mean we've great
guys on the board but there's a degree
to which when I describe some of the
things we're going through I knew that I
wanted more operational depth on our
board but the money guys said they
wanted on the board guess what as I
described them what we were facing with
the sales team or with other operational
issues or the lack of management issues
this isn't what the finance guys were
good at they just didn't know how to
deal with this and that that's very
frustrating that wasted time and then
I'm gonna open it up to questions to the
to the classroom so I mentioned the one
that we you know we bought it on
September 5th about a week before
basically the high-end retail market
really cratered and turns out we were in
high-end retail
so again one of the things that would
that deviated was the market and so what
that did is we had this great transition
plan where I was gonna because the
basically the three owners and executive
team were stepping out of the business I
was stepping in so we're gonna have this
nice casual sort of hundred day plan as
I learned the business
well that wasn't that that was a luxury
we no longer had so that was a big
difference and and honestly looking back
these guys said what I would say is that
I wish I would have moved faster to make
some changes I kind of knew my gut were
the right things to do and I you know I
let them linger on because you know for
one reason the other oh you don't want
to you know you don't want to go and
shoot the person who's been there
forever that could have an impact on the
culture but you know what you knew was
the right thing to do and you're looking
like I just lost two to three months
where I could have been making forward
progress I said so those are things I
definitely would would do going forward
that really is the biggest one I think
you know in the upside is that we've
turned out we've got a real brand that
we bought and you know when you do
diligence it's really really hard to
figure that out you can figure out you
know the balance sheet you'll probably
find some surprises but really is is
that real brand there so even though you
know the markets down our market shares
up a lot so again I think it's just you
know you got to adapt and that's one
nice thing about if you've you know made
some mistakes before that's experience
that you you feel a bit more confident
adapting when things aren't going as you
expected let's open it up to questions
in the costume that Dennis so the
question is I'm gonna repeat it for the
video have you heard of cert people have
done search funds outside of the states
is that for anyone in particular I can
come up with them sorry my computer
somewhere but that before we went out
there'd already being a couple of guys
who are relatively successful in the UK
and since then we've heard from multiple
folks who wanted to do it in South
America and Mexico so I can get you
names
what do you find this process that
really surprised you about yourself yet
I thought I worked hard and I thought
I'd been under stress you know working
for vc-backed companies and all that and
you know it went much deeper than I ever
anticipated and so you know there are a
lot of sleepless nights the first couple
of years and because I really had no
choice you know I couldn't just walk
away you stuck with it and you know I
made it through and and I haven't had a
sleepless night in a long time and it's
not that necessarily things are easier
but there is this tremendous Hill you
have to get over and and once you get
over it you kind of find out you know
it's such a cliche but those things that
don't kill you make you stronger they do
you know you you find out hopefully you
find out that you've got a much you know
deeper capacity to overcome things than
you ever imagined they are don't know if
this answers your question directly but
I will tell you that the most rewarding
part of the whole thing was my
partnership with with Mike who's still
running the company and who's just this
guy didn't know well before we started
doing the search together and we worked
together for about three months before
we decided to tell people we're gonna
raise a fund it's trying get to know
each other better and you know I think
it's like anything else in life for me I
think as you do things as a team that
the highs are just that much higher and
the lows are easier to manage and that
was an incredibly rewarding component of
it I got two things just how little I
know or how little I knew last year I
turned 37 and I was talking to Joel
Peterson about this in the parking lot
as well basically and I described and
agreed with other business owners on
this there comes a point it's like man I
got to speed up how much I learned I
read more business books now than I ever
learned more on leadership than I've
ever read in addition the other thing
beyond improving on those skills is one
big skill I needed to learn for running
the business was I ended up taking
meditation classes because
I just couldn't sleep I mean just the
crap that's waking me at 3:00 and 4:00
in the morning like that frickin VP of
Sales that's where I get language like
I'm gonna take you out back and shoot
you it's like at 4:00 in the morning but
it's the Michaels point it was the it's
the level of intensity was quite
something it's like known are you gonna
make the debt payment are you gonna make
the quarter it's like whoa
so I'd to learn a lot this is a great
question I think it we're trying to
change the culture and how people work
at the company and so every once in
while you'll see that person you know is
really leveraged if they decide to jump
on board they make a comment where like
all those things you've been trying to
work on them different ways you can't
just say directly it's coming out of
them and they're being self-directed in
a way you'd like it to be and you're
like you know that that's good so when I
do by the way I have a piece of paper
and pen next to my bag because I wake up
so much I just write it down at least
seems to let me go back to sleep
great idea I mean I did that somewhat
and where I failed on the execution
standpoint we've we've hit a lot as I
did in a very undercapitalized way which
forced me to not move forward and
execute on some of the strategic ideas I
had I mean it specifically was I was
going to go and do things differently
because I had a lot of experience at
industry and I saw where people were I
thought we were failing so I still think
it's mal it's gonna take me longer to
get there and I would do differently
would have followed Jim's advice and
bought a bigger company because as he
told me he says you know Michael it's
just as easy to buy a big company as a
small company and so if I approached it
differently in terms of being better
capitalized on it with a better
management team in other words a better
face I believe I could have gotten there
sooner to execute on I'm sort of you
know building a better mousetrap if you
will I think I think that you got to be
careful with that idea I mean I think
these are little businesses I mean
really the Michaels point and events get
in the way you know events whether it's
you know customers quittin or even
signing up a new customer or employees
quitting or what have you and I think
the idea of I've got a great strategy
and now I'm just looking for a company
to execute against us look if it's a
phenomenally powerful strategy then I
guess you know it can work but I just
think it can be dangerous you know you
got to treat each investment as a you
know it's got a wash its face on its own
and it's got to grow on its own and
that's hard to do so you know that's not
to say you know look if you think that
there's a business where there's a set
of interesting consolidation to be done
or kind of a new set of products to be
rolled out that it can't be neat and it
can't work but I just feel like you need
to know the industry extraordinarily
well and I think it's very easy from the
outside to think that things are easy to
do strategically and to think that
people in the industry just aren't very
smart and they haven't thought of it
before and one of the things that
continues to astonish me is how
incredibly bright people are that found
businesses and build them from nothing
to real businesses are making money and
just thinking you've probably got a
smarter idea than them a lot of the time
you don't there's a reason why they
haven't done some of the stuff that's
out there so I just I just be careful
that's all
thanks Richie Victor
you know these guys points what I did is
with my two investors is I myself having
been on executive staffs of companies
that were venture backed I sort of tried
to force myself to do that sort of
reporting so even though I spent you
know a lot of emphasis on gaining
control and I could sort of you know
tell as much or as little I suppose as I
wanted I use my investors to force
myself to report to them on on monthly
quarterly annual basis and so as much as
I wasn't necessarily expecting to get a
lot of wonderful insight out of them
i I did use them as a gauge to say okay
here the results here's here's my
strategy here's what I'm gonna do and it
was their third third-party validation
if you will so so ultimately that's how
I approached it I tried to force myself
to do the reporting and analysis that is
really super difficult to do when you're
battling with the day-to-day stuff to
just sit down and run a balance sheet in
the PNL and analyze it and come up with
bullet points of why you're doing
something right or wrong is is is
amazingly difficult to find the time
I started I was looking to buy a good
company with excellent growth potential
so I wasn't looking to buy a you know
rock bottom company at a rock-bottom
price because I you know I really do
think growth is the the engine that's
going to drive your performance in these
type of deals so I was flexible and what
that could mean but that that was it and
I wanted to buy one that's I've a
certain size just for me personally plus
I think your the options you have to do
different things are better when you're
a 3 million Eva da company versus a
million even da we wanted to build we
wanted to buy a great company at a fair
price and that's you know it's exactly
that a lot of growth prospects and
something that we felt was a we were
perfectly paired prepared to pay up for
you know pay a fair price for a great
business much more important than buying
we wanted one that already was going
like this we just wanted to keep it
going like that that's that's what we
were looking for so there's all the
criteria in the books that you know
folks talked about the number one thing
we were looking for was growth and we
were looking for multiple ways to win we
had a business that was fitting off cash
and there was this little growth piece I
I think that yeah I think in general
these companies are bought cheaply or at
low multiples but frequently I think a
lot of search funders would agree buy a
good company and some there was a bit of
talk about it not being a very efficient
market at the size of these buyouts
I think it's shocking when you actually
get out on the field that all these
companies or private equity firms that
are out saying we look at companies of 5
million plus and cashflow they're
Dennett looking at stuff with one and a
half million in cash flow it's horribly
scary at what the competition is against
you and Alpine who's across the street
from us yeah so those guys they got
people who are making calls all day long
and they're calling the same folks we're
calling it's very very efficient so
finding a good company is really what
you're looking for and growth is
probably the number one criterion that
we were looking at and the ones criteria
I think we screwed up on with
scalability the original business that
we
he went into it just couldn't with the
right resources could not just go like
that just the business we're building
has that one quick comment just on the
conversation that was had around you
know do you make your turns by buying
cheap or do you make your returns by you
know by growing the heck out of them and
one of the things about the search fund
is it set up the abide chief basically
your investors you got to convince a
whole bunch of people that this is a
good deal not just one set of people and
you know it's your first time buying
something and blah blah blah there's a
whole bunch of risk etc etc people
aren't prepared to pay up and pay you
know kind of ten times EBIT down
multiples for a first time CEO who's
going to change control deal where the
founder CEO is exiting and that's to me
at least that's inherently why a lot of
search fund deals do look somewhat cheap
from a multiple perspective but i will
tell you i don't think that's what
drives the returns that you'll get a 30
percent pop or something like that from
buying something at four and a half five
times it maybe should go for six or
seven these days that's great so you
made 35 percent you want to make 35
percent IRR over six years you got to
keep that going for a long time but
anyway so I think search deals are just
are they they are inherently cheap
because otherwise your equity providers
aren't going to be there for you
questions Jason
it is I mean honestly just going back to
the sleepless nights thing you know
doing it alone I guess on the personal
level if your spouse isn't on board
don't do it I mean just it's it's it's
not gonna happen
and you know I I had I bought a company
conceived our first child my wife
started graduate school at UCSF and we
moved all within 12 months and if it
wasn't for my wife and her her parents
just couldn't just never would have
happened if we didn't have if I didn't
have that kind of support at home in
fact that I had an individual that came
for an entrepreneurial family and you
know grew up with parents that had a
deli that was open to 364 days a year
and technical on vacation with her
because they couldn't leave the deli and
so she would go on vacation with aunts
and uncles I mean she got it she really
did and I'm so really in retrospect
because I it's not like I chose her for
those qualities I'd like to say I was
that prescient
but but honestly you know interview your
spouse
I mean figure out if you if you're in a
family environment that that can do this
because I I honestly we never would have
made it through without her personal
makeup and then the support of her
family helping with the the two kids
that we've have a five year old in the 2
year old and I fell in the company 7
years so do the math it's you know been
impossible without him so so as far it
would've been nice to have a partner it
would have been nice to be able to leave
for a week and go on vacation I didn't
take my first week off until year five
and you know that you know all my all my
vacations were you know three-day
weekends and so it would have been
really nice to have a partner that I
felt like I could just you know here are
the keys I'll be back in a week don't
call me
I think on the partners side of things
they're also advantages I mean to me
that the as I said earlier on I guess
you know the key piece here is making
sure if you are going to take the risk
you got to make sure that you're
minimizing it right so what are the you
know both a lot of times what ends up
happening is you just buy a business
that frankly doesn't end up being as
good as you hope that was prior to
purchasing and so one of the things that
you can do that can ensure prior to the
acquisition that you've done everything
you can to make sure you you've been
honest and done as much diligence as you
can and having a partner is a way to do
that it's not the only way to do that
but structurally for us having a
situation where each of us run our own
deals and the other person played a
devil's advocate role and push pretty
hard and said I think this business
sucks because and every Friday afternoon
one of the two of us would be on the hot
seat explaining what we've been doing
and what the deals where we were working
on the other person just sat there just
chucking rocks at the other guy
basically saying here's why it sucks
that was a huge source of value for us
for both of us I mean it got me my
partner was just much better at
approaching companies and getting stuff
up and running and having a bunch of
irons in the fire and I was great at
analyzing each iron that I had perfectly
that was total waste of time because the
vast majority of the time nothing
happens right you really in the business
is saying no when you're doing a search
fund right you got to get through the no
deals as fast as you can rather than the
business of saying yes and having
somebody there who's efficient at
helping you run through the nose and
doing it quicker and more honestly which
was huge for us there are other ways to
do it but that was a big deal I think
I'm running the business it's great to
have a partner and you know from an
emotional and psychic perspective it's
great to run a Java partner and you know
the reality is if it's all going to work
out pretty well you have you have less
equity you've left equity in some of
these deals too one sort of Eber comment
I guess and this thing is you doing
absolutely everything you can to make
sure the transaction is a success that's
the really important thing your share
there of whether it's 10 percent 15 20
30 it's just nowhere near gonna matter
anywhere near as much as that it's a
success and not a failure or it's a home
run and not a double those those are the
things that make all the difference in
the world
and so my partner took you know half the
economics that I took obviously and that
reduced significantly theoretically what
was available for us in the deal and I'm
the luckiest guy in the world that I did
because he added way way more you know
from that whether it's through the deal
process or subsequently and running the
company then that ever cost me in my
for the economics in our transaction I'm
gonna just ask you guys to make closing
comments here and if there's any time
until before 6:15 we'll take take some
last questions but if you would just
focus them any closing comments you want
a really anything you want to talk about
that we haven't touched on you know
advice for four people in the class and
and anything that you would if you did
it over again if you do differently
that'd be great no I just go yes right
so one key thing I mean I don't expect
your investors act rationally I one of
the key components of this business I
was counting on was one of my investors
was supposed to bring me a significant
amount of revenue and I thought you know
well maybe I didn't really think about
too clearly it's like oh he's an
investor of course that money that
revenue would just come those sales will
just come and in those first five years
where I took the company from from two
million three point eight million that
had nothing to do with him and had those
dollars come I should have taken that
company from two to six or seven million
so I guess the one thing is is you know
anything that you expect any a key
assumption anything you want is you know
have some teeth get it in writing have
some contractual obligation that people
are going to follow through and and and
never when it comes to investors assume
that well they've got equity in the
company they're gonna make the same
rational decision that you think's
rational they're not standing is acting
in irrational there there's a rational
method behind I've never figured it out
but it's not it didn't turn out the way
I thought and that was a key thing that
I would do differently um if you go this
route focus on getting a great business
the David's said this several times in
this meeting in some format and in other
forms just focus on getting that great
business it makes everything so much
easier then live within your means here
you know whether it's entrepreneurship
through acquisition or some other form
of entrepreneurship everything goes
haywire if you don't get good about your
personal financial planning and your
needs and if you're thinking I'd like to
do this in five years well
plan for that because guess what in five
years your cash flow is probably going
to really suck so plan and if that's
really what you want to do in five years
fill the financial plan around that and
make it happen and then lastly on the
support item you there's David and I had
partners but then there's the partners
at home and I don't think there's a
statistic in here but what you start to
discover when you call search funders
around the country is it's mostly guys
and it's mostly married guys because
this is this reality of you know the
company that you're acquiring could be
taking you to Knoxville Tennessee which
could be great if you're from Knoxville
Tennessee and you want to go home to
your family but for the narration of
what an English guy my partner wanted to
take me to the middle of Louisiana and I
really had to commit sit down or what
that meant but you got to build those
support mechanisms around you you just
do it it's a big undertaking and you've
got to make sure that the people are
there who are gonna look after you
emotionally throughout this process so I
he took my bullet because I had my last
name's Callahan we always talk about
team Callahan that's my wife and I she
has made a lot of sacrifices you know so
that we could get the experiences we
want it but absolutely agree there's
there's definitely like because we could
have gone anywhere and she's from Sydney
Australia so Knoxville Tennessee wasn't
that appealing to her but we agreed up
front and what she would and would not
do the yeah and I just say think about
this part of your career not a you know
one and done and I'm off to sit on the
beach after this that'll probably make
you think about planning it better and
and as David said I think I'm just
focused on a success I'm not focused on
getting rich off this deal if I make
good money that that's obviously a great
thing but but I want these guys to want
to put me in a bigger company the next
round so Sean just took one of mine for
sure which is you got to take it think
about this as part of a 40-year career
not kind of what you want to do now as
soon as you graduate from business
school I just think that's incredibly
important in thinking about the sets of
skills you want to pick up over the time
period of your career as opposed to
simply you know what do I want to do
next month
I think the key thing is you got to
recognize if this is a path you're going
to go down the odds are it's not going
to work three times out of four it
doesn't and the other three folks are
just as smart as the one where it does
and I guarantee you and I've seen both
you know all four of those folks and
they're not that impressive if you
recognize that most the time it's not
going to work if you recognize that most
of time it's not going to work then you
sort of start to say okay so what does
that mean for me the first thing is you
realize that in failure there are
different kinds of failure here the
first you know in rank order the things
you want to do our do a great deal do no
deal whatsoever do a bad deal right in
that order and and you want to do
everything you can to avoid being in the
do a bad deal Puckett and recognize that
frankly again most search funders don't
succeed in doing that it doesn't work
out terribly well but you're gonna do
everything you can to do that and so
that's all around so your search process
people you get money from how you think
about it you know whether or not which
one of these three transactions you'll
go through in terms of the structure for
me there's no doubt you would do the
funded search if you can you have an
involved committed experience set of
people who will help you with diligence
they will help you find deals they will
help you negotiate deals they will help
you find the little Easter eggs that are
hidden there inside of the financials or
the legal problems you do everything you
can to minimize the chances you think
about a partner if you don't think that
maybe you're able to do it yourself
and/or you're able to run the company
well yourself from a timing perspective
you ask yourself am I ready today am I
really ready to put my career on the
line as a CEO of a business or they're
things that I should learn in the
interim and I think you give up control
you give up economics you do everything
you can to make sure that the deal
you're involved in the deal you do is a
success one or that you don't do a deal
at all those are the things I think the
final thing I think is and you're all
doing it just by virtue of being here
today
but I think it's you try and learn from
smart people and the accumulated
mistakes of those smart people and God
knows I mean I think the CES with Linda
just does a phenomenal job on capturing
as much of the wisdom and the network of
folks that are out there I think the
fact that you can get folks like David
and Peter teaching this class is just
it's one of the things makes it just be
an amazing place to be out that the
accumulated wisdom of David and Peter in
this
process it's just is extraordinary you
guys would be lucky to get time with
them if you were thinking of doing a
search fun they're actually here
teaching the class the fact that Jim
Ellis is here or what have you
there are so many smart folks that have
made most of the mistakes that are
necessary in this and so be wise and
learn from those people rather than you
know try and be smart and make your own
mistakes if you will great thank you all
for very much